he is the voice of pro football talk
live on NBCSN and of course football
night in America insider and the great
website pro football talk.com
Mike I want to start with Jason Witten
the possibility of him was there a
possibility of him coming out of the
broadcast booth to play for the Cowboys
this year there was a possibility would
before week 13 that's one of the things
to read Williams of PFC nailed down
after week 13 and courts identity this
report comes out week 14 but after week
13 you can't just bring a guy back who's
on the retirement you have to pass
through waivers first so it would have
been complicated somebody else could
have screwed it up by making the waivers
claim on Jason Witten but I look at it
this way he's working for ESPN ESPN
reports that he was talking to the
Cowboys about coming back surely there
was some conversation with Jason Witten
the ESPN employee before they went with
that report that would be like me
pulling on football night in America
saying Tony Dungy is thinking about
coming out of retirement to coach the
Buccaneers without talking to Dungy
before doing it so I think even though
it was denied by the Cowboys very loudly
there had to have been something to it
or it never would have been a report
published by ESPN yeah I had heard
earlier in the year when you know that
receiving corps was not doing anything
and this is before Amari Cooper that
they were that desperate they they were
trying to get somebody that who could be
a go-to target for Jack Prescott and
then when this came out and by the way
Witten said no I'm committed to this and
this is what I want to do and it was you
know the right answer I think at the
time but the fact that it came out now
then I thought maybe there was something
to it but how does Dallas not know the
rules of a bring in Jason Witten out of
retirement well they could have brought
in before week 13 it would have been
very easy all he has to do is set AI
unretired you sent a letter to
Commissioner we went through this with
Brett Favre ten years ago it's very
simple it's very easy and the Cowboys
would still have him under contract it's
after week 13 where you can't just
automatically do it and that's why for
this to come out week 14 it's impossible
that it's gonna happen now and I think
you're right Dan they were desperate
before they got Amari Cooper and I
criticized them for trading a
first-round pick for Amari Cooper in
large part because it's a different
Amari Cooper the
we saw in Oakland so kudos to the
Cowboys for coaching this guy up that
he's playing like a guy who would have
been worth more than a first-round pick
and I don't know what the Raiders did
with Cooper did not press his butt to
get the kind of performance that we've
seen him produce in Dallas the Oakland
lawsuit against the Raiders what do you
make of this well you know I'm in the
process of trying to break it all down
now and understand it basically it's an
antitrust lawsuit that argues that the
NFL put in place a relocation policy
that ultimately lets the NFL leverage
cities and profits from relocation fees
the team's plug pay when they when they
move like the Chargers and the Rams to
LA and with the Raiders moving to Las
Vegas it's 1.4 billion that gets
redistributed among the teams so there's
a profit incentive to let these teams
move and they don't follow the their own
relocation policy and all of that is
going to be bootstrapped into an
argument that the federal antitrust laws
are being violated and that's one thing
to remember in a case like this you've
got 32 separate businesses that come
together and make collective decisions
and anytime that happens anytime you've
got distinct businesses that are making
decisions about what one specific
business is going to do or not do that's
when you tread into antitrust territory
and that's where the NFL needs to be
concerned and you know the entire
National Football League the fact that
you've got these 32 separate businesses
working together
it isn't walking antitrust violation and
that's why if they were to start the NFL
today it would be one company in any new
league that is founded now it's one
company and that's the easy way around
the antitrust laws and that's what the
NFL is going to have to deal with here
and I think as a business matter Dan
regardless what happens with a law
student will probably hang around for
three or four years or longer
what's the Raiders going to do next year
where are they gonna play no they gonna
play in Oakland or where they gonna play
their stadiums not going to be ready in
Las Vegas there's been reports they're
not going to play at Sam Boyd Stadium
where do they go for a year or two if
Oakland has the door slammed on it
permanently a couple other things here
Cam Newton in that shoulder like why it
feels like there's something to it it
feels like but I don't know how serious
this is is it an aggravation is a
injured or is there nothing well it
hasn't been right all year and I think
it came to a head in that game against
the bus and years when he tried to throw
a Hail Mary and it came up 15 yards
short of the end zone and they brought
in Taylor Heinicke to throw it the
second time and tie Nicki's draft
analysis Cummings illegals he doesn't
have a strong arm and he's the guy who's
throwing the Hail Mary instead of cam
dude so there's something going on with
that shoulder he's had surgery on it in
the past and I think this is gonna be
one of those things where we get through
the season and then there'll be an
announcement at some point in January
that he's had successful shoulder
surgery and he'll be ready to go at the
start of the season and maybe it'll show
up on Jim Marcy's Twitter account Wow
Carson Wentz dealing with the back issue
not expected to play this week yeah well
alive I mean with the Vikings listening
to the Seahawks on Monday night and the
Vikings and disarray one of those teams
that is hovering at 6 and 7 has a chance
to rise up and when you've got the Rams
the Texans over the next two weeks if
you don't have Carson Wentz it's gonna
be harder to win but it's a great chance
for Nick Foles is he's getting ready to
become a pre agent no it's funny I was
thinking of the free agent quarterback
for 2019 the other day and I forgot all
about things balls what was shame well
you know when this guy finally gets to
the market he will be the guy that
nobody is thinking of and maybe this
will be a chance for him to come back
and remind everyone that he could still
play at a high level and he gets a
chance to get paid in March I also
wondered this Mike and you know I'm just
spitballing this but I wanted to know
this is prior to Lamar Jackson this past
weekend but I assume the job is now his
if I'm Jacksonville I kick the tires on
bringing in Joe Flacco it's an upgrade a
steadier presence a better better
quarterback got playoff experience no
drama with him what's the land you know
is Tom Coughlin gonna be the head coach
next year so I I don't know what do you
think of those thoughts I like that I
mean I took the tires on anyone other
than Blake bortles at this point and
last year they had plenty of options at
their disposal and they chose none of
them they chose to stick with portals
this year there are going to be fewer
options and one of them is going to be
Joe Flacco and the thing I like about
flacco but i also don't like this when
slack though has a bug up his butt he
plays better now you'd prefer that
consistency and you play well all the
time but back in 2012 when he thought he
was being disrespected he went all-in
bet on himself won the Super Bowl got
the big contract and then earlier this
year when he was healthy he was playing
well because people were talking about
how Lamar Jackson's gonna take over some
if you give him a chip on his shoulder
and you send him to Jacksonville maybe
you get one or two really good years out
of him before he gets complacent again
you think Coughlin will coach that team
next year I'd be surprised if he does I
yeah I don't know I think that there's
gonna be some change is it you know the
change they made offensive coordinator a
couple weeks ago that's not hey
last-ditch effort to try to make the
playoffs I think that's an effort by
Doug Marrone to blame somebody else for
something that ultimately falls back on
him can I can you think of another team
that had everybody coming back
everything looked like it was pointing
up and it's like an entire top to bottom
organizational exhale where they forgot
everything they had to do last year to
get a good point where they were where
they were you know a Final Four team
like after they beat the Patriots and
what the to a No I think they just
wanted to fast-forward to the postseason
and they just completely lost their way
and and Doug Marrone is the guy's
day-to-day that's in charge of making
sure these guys are on the right path
good stuff Mike thanks for joining us as
always all right that's Mike Florio pro
football talk live on NBCSN for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]